Here I have painted four different
molecules of triglycerides.
You can say,
"Wait, I thought triglycerides"
"have many carbon, hydrogen and oxygen atoms."
"And here I see only oxygen,"
"where are all carbon and hydrogen atoms?"
My answer is that they are implied by the structural fool.
This is a short way to display
of these large molecules.
You will see these folks very often
in Chemistry, Biology, and Organic Chemistry.
Every one
of these tapered parts along the chain,
all of these points mean carbon atoms.
There is one carbon atom here, one here.
One - here
Also,
if there is no letter at the end of the chain,
has a carbon atom here.
It is understood that there is a carbon atom here,
there is a carbon atom here and there.
You may be wondering about
hydrogen atoms?
We assume that each carbon atom has four covalent bonds.
If any of these carbon atoms are present
additional covalent links,
we assume that these covalent bonds are hydrogen.
For example, this carbon atom
there are two covalent bonds.
So the other two covalent bonds,
will have hydrogen atoms.
The same is the situation with this carbon atom.
It is linked to two hydrogen atoms.
At this carbon atom,
we see only one covalent bond.
So there must be three more covalent bonds.
These three covalent bonds are hydrogen.
All carbon and hydrogen atoms are here.
They are implied by the structural formula.
Now you can see if you are not,
you can pause the video
and think about the difference
between this triglyceride, this triglyceride,
this and that.
Maybe you will think fast.
We see this triglyceride
there are no double bonds.
This triglyceride has one double bond.
This one has several double bonds.
And this one has several double bonds.
But the two are different,
and we will think about how they differ.
You can immediately see that one
turns and bends,
while this remains fairly straightforward.
This is the main difference.
We will talk about this in a second,
why it's happening.
But let's first look at this triglyceride.
When we have all these single links,
we can imagine,
that we have put as many hydrogen atoms as possible
of the carbon chain.
In other words,
we have saturated that hydrogen-containing fat.
That's why this triglyceride is saturated fat.
Saturated, it's saturated fat.
You may have heard of saturated fat,
when talking about things like oil.
They have many different fats that
we associate with a solid aggregate at room temperature.
And the reason to be solid at room temperature is,
that all these hydrogen atoms are connected.
There are no folds to form double bonds.
Their molecules may be relatively compressed,
which makes them solid
at room temperature.
Saturated fats are sometimes linked -
I do not want to go into controversy
for and against saturated fats,
but saturated fat sometimes
are called bad fats.
As we shall see, however, they are not the worse fat.
The worse fat is actually here.
We'll talk about this in a second.
It is saturated fat,
because it is saturated with as many hydrogen atoms as possible.
This triglyceride on the right,
I do not know anything about him,
there are all these single links.
Or all these single bonds between carbon atoms.
Here we see a double link.
We see a double bond between this and this carbon atom.
Therefore
this carbon atom already has three covalent bonds,
therefore it will be connected to only one hydrogen atom.
He already has three covalent bonds,
so it will only be connected to one hydrogen atom,
unlike these two carbon atoms here.
Therefore, we do not
maximum number of hydrogen atoms in the chain.
That is why we call this triglyceride unsaturated fat.
Unsaturated fat.
We do not have the greatest possible number of hydrogen atoms that can be chained into the chain.
Because of this fat is unsaturated.
In particular, polyunsaturated fats
double bonds tend to form
folds in the structure,
which prevent molecules from being very compressed in space,
therefore unsaturated fats are most often liquid
at room temperature.
It's an unsaturated fat.
There's a lot here
double bonds.
It's called polyunsaturated fat.
Polyunsaturated fat.
And since -
both are unsaturated fat.
It's polyunsaturated fat.
Because this one has only one double bond
we can call it monounsaturated fat.
These are two unsaturated fats.
There are many double bonds, so - skirts.
There is only one double bond here, so it's called monounsaturated fat.
One question you can ask is,
"Why are there folds in"
"this molecule and this molecule,"
"not in this molecule,"
"although it also has double bonds?".
The reason is our good friends
cis and trance.
Maybe you remember,
that if we have a double bond between carbon atoms -
Let's say we have,
one configuration.
I will draw it like that.
Let's say we have a configuration where
this is related to a carbon chain,
and let's say it's a hydrogen atom.
And on the other side is the rest of the carbon chain,
it may be in one of two configurations.
The rest
of the carbon chain can
to be on the same side as the carbon chain on the left.
I'll write R here.
I will paint it in the same color.
We have hydrogen.
This is one configuration.
The other configuration would be
double bond between two carbon atoms.
We have a hydrogen atom, but now the hydrogen atoms
are from opposite sides.
Also the chains -
the rest of the carbon chains
are from opposite sides.
As we have said before,
this is because the double bonds are immobile.
There can be no rotation around them.
Therefore, these molecules are actually different
isomers.
It matters whether this circuit is
from the same side with this chain.
Whether they are from the same country.
When they are from the same country,
we call this cis configuration,
and this is a trance, trans configuration.
It turns out that most of the natural,
produced unsaturated fats are in cis configuration.
Because they are in cis configuration
whenever we have double links,
they bend the chain.
And if we have many double bonds,
they bend the chain a lot.
Therefore, polyunsaturated fats very often
are liquid. It is very difficult for their molecules to stand close together, to be compressed.
What is going on in here?
These molecules are in the configuration,
in which
the rest of the carbon chains
are on the opposite sides of the double bond.
Note this carbon chain
is above the double bond.
Forms a covalent link up.
While this carbon chain here,
is under the double bond.
Because of this no bump is formed,
this is the trans configuration.
This here
is called trans fat.
This is called trans fat.
They usually do not meet
in nature.
Interesting about trans fats is that
many people say, "Okay,"
"maybe saturated fats are bad for us,"
"maybe we should not eat so much butter."
This is still a matter of many debates.
Some people say, "Well, if we start with unsaturated fat?".
They are often considered healthier,
like our polyunsaturated fat here.
Add some hydrogen atoms,
not to saturate it fully,
but enough to disappear
some double bonds.
This will make it harder at room temperature,
which will make it a good substitute for cooking oil.
Many of the margarines you may have seen
10-15 years ago, as well as today,
are trans fats.
So here
we can replace many of these double bonds,
we can fill them with more hydrogen atoms.
But in this process,
some of the cis double bonds
are transformed into trans double bonds.
And first people said, "Oh, that's harmless,"
"maybe even good for health, fat is still unsaturated."
But it has some of the properties of saturated fat.
Margarine is solid and has an oily taste.
And it may be cheaper to manufacture.
You can do it from other oils.
But it turns out to be very unhealthy.
There are many controversial questions about nutrition,
but margarine is really unhealthy.
It does not exist in nature
and has a variety of negative effects on the body.
That is why in many states and even countries
have forbidden trans fats.
I've even heard people
to call them "poisonous to the body"
in certain ways.
They have a strong negative effect.
This may sound very loud,
I guess I'm trying to scare you a little.
But do not eat trans fats.
Anyway, I hope you enjoyed the video.